and the proposition reads the right way
to persuade people of libertarianism is
by showing them that its outcomes are
superior without any resort to the
flawed non-aggression principle the
reader one the right way to persuade
people of libertarianism is by showing
them that its outcomes are superior
without any resort to the flawed
non-aggression principle of flawed
principle you see how that adjective is
underlined and uh two 78 year old
libertarian is discussing it double that
you get 156 years of libertarian wisdom
grappling with that issue so this could
be your lucky day I now give I now give
uh the the podium over to Dennis Pratt
moderator
thank you
thanks a lot Gene
in Yiddish there are twice the number of
words for arguments then for happy
and so therefore here on the great
porcupine Freedom stage
For Your Entertainment we bring to you
together
two great Jewish mentions convection For
Your Entertainment
the resolution the right way to persuade
people of libertarianism is by showing
them
that its outcomes are superior by their
standards
without any resort to the flawed
non-aggression principle
in this corner
for the affirmative
a mixed economy practice uh oops sorry a
mixed Economist legal scholar and
anarcho capitalist Haley from the
authoritarian 49th state of California
weighing in at 78 years of age
David no my father wasn't a communist
Freedman
thank you
[Applause]
how you doing let's take a seat
and in this corner
for the negative of mixed Economist
practitioner running the world written
down debate series The Soho for him
hailing from the authoritarian 49 state
of New York
City
waited also at 78 years of age Gene no
my brother's not Jeffrey Epstein
[Applause]
we will start with 17 and a half minutes
to establish the case of the resolution
with David Friedman
[Applause]
I am going to be making two different
arguments the sorry is this turned on
yeah
I don't really need a mic in a room this
small
there are two different arguments I have
to make the first is to show what is
wrong with the nap
the second is to show why you do not
need the nap to argue for libertarianism
the nap as I understand it and as it's
usually presented is an absolute rule
what it says is you should never
initiate coercion as best I can tell
nobody including no libertarian actually
believes in it and my standard example
of that which was invented by the late
Bill Bradford who was the founder and
editor of Liberty magazine is to imagine
that you manage to fall off your 10th
floor balcony
by good luck catch hold of the flagpole
of the ninth floor balcony
and are working your way hand over hand
on back to the balcony when the owner of
the apartment comes out and says you do
not have my permission to use my
flagpole
how many people here raise your hand if
you would let go
all right I think that confirms uh my
claim that nobody actually believes in
the nap as it is normally stated uh a
less extreme example that I have
sometimes used is to imagine that there
is a Madman with a rifle shooting at a
crowd of people it just happens there is
a rifle close to you that you could use
to kill him unfortunately it belongs to
somebody who is publicly announced that
he never wants anybody else to use his
rifle
using his rifle to kill the Killer is a
violation of his property rights it is
forbidden by the nap I won't pull people
this time but my guess is that most of
you would be in favor of grabbing the
rifle
uh
there are two ways I've seen of trying
to evade the conclusion that the nap
although a very useful rule of thumb is
not the kind of absolute principle that
Libertarians routinely claim it is one
of them is to say that the real
objective is not to never violate rights
or to never initiate coercion but to
minimize the violation of Rights so you
could then say that in the uh case of
the
of of the of the mass killer when you
seize a rifle that's a much smaller
violation of Rights than what you're
stopping and therefore you're entitled
to do it uh
the problem with that is that if that's
your position you no longer have an
adequate argument for libertarian
conclusions because now the people who
disagree with you will say well yes
indeed taxation is the violation of your
property rights but we need the money in
order to pay police and soldiers to
prevent people from being coerced by
criminals in foreign countries
so you are then thrown back on an
essentially consequentialist argument on
trying to argue that you can
successfully protect rights without
government taxation uh you the nap no
longer buys you anything once you turn
it from a statement of what you want to
what you may do to what you want to
minimize
a different way in which I've seen
people try to deal with this problem is
to say that it's all right to violate
rights as long as you compensate the
victim
now to begin with that means that you
now approve of eminent domain is
currently used by the government because
eminent domain consists of seizing
property and then paying what is claimed
to be a fair compensation for it
more generally how do you decide what a
fair compensation is and I think the
Instinct of most Libertarians would be
what the owner of the property is
willing to accept but the owner of the
property might not be willing to accept
any payment that you can make he might
not be willing to accept any payment at
all so I think neither of those
solves the fundamental problem which is
that the nap itself is a position that
nobody really believes in it it's good
for rhetoric it lets you feel yummy uh
you can say look at those evil people
who want to initiate coercion but in
fact you would yourself be in favor of
initiating coercion under some
imaginable circumstances so your
fundamental disagreement is that you
don't think those circumstances exist
that you believe we are in a rural world
where we can prevent horrible things
from happening without initiating
coercion that's a consequentialist
argument not a moral argument the second
problem with the non-aggression with the
nap
is that it is a moral argument
and unfortunately we have no way of
deriving moral arguments
Iran thought she did you can find a
chapter in the Third Edition of my book
Machinery of Freedom which is dedicated
to taking apart her claimed argument
which I believe does not hold up one of
the Striking things about Rand is that
whenever there's a hole in her argument
she covers it up with beautiful rhetoric
very good writer very brave woman I
should say and an original woman she's
just wrong about quite a lot of things
probably I'm wrong about quite a lot of
things too but I don't know which ones
uh
the
so as far as I can tell David Hume was
correct when he argued in the 18th
century that there is no way of proving
moral conclusions from the facts of
reality no way of getting from is to
ought and if there's no way of getting
from is to ought then even if you were
happy even if you believed in the nap
you have no response to the person who
says why should I believe that you have
no way of showing him that the nap is in
fact a correct moral rule which is what
you need to do
so that's the basis of my claim that the
nap is not in fact a satisfactory basis
for defending libertarianism nor is it
even a principle that people really
believe in
so the next step somebody who's thinking
very quickly might say but if you cannot
derive any normative conclusions if you
have no way of showing what's morally
right how can you make any arguments at
all for what should happen and the
answer to that is that I don't have to
derive moral arguments I don't have to
derive values because all of the people
I want to con convince already have
moral beliefs
so I don't have to show what moral
beliefs are true I only have to show
that in terms of their beliefs not the
stated principles that they say but what
ends they want
my system is better than the than the
alternatives
uh
If You observe people you find that in
fact most people agree mostly on what
outcomes are desirable their beliefs
aren't identical they give different
weights to different things but as far
as I can tell I've never yet heard
anybody argue that the reason his
economic system is better is that it
produces more poverty
or more disease
or more ignorance or Worse novels uh
that as far as I can tell pretty much
everybody if you look at the arguments
they actually make
believes in about the same set of values
not identical values and the reason that
they Proclaim different principles is
they disagree about what principles lead
to what values
uh
I was struck quite a long time ago by
the fact that if you look at the
arguments that marxists make
they seem to agree with our principles
because in theory Marxism says from each
according to his ability to each
according to his needs and it would
follow from that that if workers are
good at working they should do the
working and if billionaires need rolls
royces they should get rolls royces but
in fact the Marxist argument on
exploitation is the claim that
everything is produced by the workers
some of it is consumed by the
capitalists and that's wrong well if
that's a Libertarian argument they've
got the economics wrong
but the underlying principle is that you
get ownership of something by producing
it which is our principle
uh
the reason that this is enough the
reason that the imperfect agreement on
ends is sufficient is that a Libertarian
Society is not just a little bit better
than the alternatives
all right if it were the case that we
really faced the choice do we have a
welfare state or a complete less Affair
system and if it were the if the answer
were with the welfare state there will
be fewer poor people but the society as
a whole will be a little bit poorer the
total income of everybody would be a
little lower than somebody who puts a
high weight on uh helping the poor might
say I prefer the welfare state but I
don't think anybody in this room
believes that that if you actually look
at the outcomes of various things
ranging from welfare states to fully
socialist systems they are not just a
little bit worse not even a little bit
worse than the outcomes of relatively
let's say for societies that have
existed let alone then at least we
believe the outcome would be of a more
fully let's say fair Society uh
most of us believe probably all of us
believe that a less Affair society would
have less poverty
interesting factoid not a proof because
correlation is not uh causation if you
look at poverty rates in the U.S over
the period since World War II You
observe that they fell steeply the
percentage of the population that was
poor by a fixed definition fell steeply
until roughly the point at which the war
on poverty got fully funded
it has been roughly constant since then
that the actual the intended effect of
the world war on poverty uh Charles
Murray's book first book discusses this
was to get people out of poverty to make
people self-supporting
actual effect was to make poverty
somewhat less imp less unpleasant and
leave people poor uh
I was struck uh some years ago when I
visited India
by the fact that India observed by a
foreigner looked like the picture of a
capitalist Society held by a loyal
communist who had never been outside of
the Soviet Union
it was a massive miserably poor people
but then there was the business school I
spoke at which was in a lovely campus
trees grass surrounded by a high wall
with barbed wire on top of it
India at that time it had a socialist
government since it was founded
when I read a novel set in the Soviet
Union
what struck me was that the obvious
difference in status and income between
the physician and that woman who cleaned
his house was enormously greater than
the difference I observed between me and
people I hired to to clean my my house
uh one of whom is a UC Irvine student or
at least was a little while ago nice
people uh
the so that if you actually look at the
results if you say what we want is a
society where you don't have massive
inequality in particular you don't have
people who are very poor most of us
believe and would argue that uh
libertarian Society is more likely to
give that result not less
people who disagree about politics quite
often put the arguments or at least
imagine them as you are evil people you
don't care if the poor starve uh or if
we're doing it you don't care if
people's rights are violated ah
putting your argument in terms of the
nap makes it easier for them to believe
that because it sounds as though you're
saying well I can't really show that
you're wrong about the consequences of
my policies but I've got this principle
which says that even if the poor starve
we still shouldn't violate property
rights uh
rhetorically speaking in terms of
persuading people that's a very stupid
argument to make whether you believe in
the nap or not because in fact we do
have good arguments we do have good
reasons to believe that the system
that we support produces better outcomes
than the systems that they support
uh I like to in an odd way this is a
rerun of a debate that I had in 1982.
that was with George Smith unfortunately
no longer alive very bright and
interesting guy and the title of that
one was economics versus philosophy
which is the better foundation for
libertarianism
and as I like to point out philosophers
still read Aristotle and economists
don't
that is to say there has actually been
quite substantial progress in economics
over the last few centuries I'm not sure
there's been regress in philosophy uh I
would have said that Rawls is probably a
step down
but there has not been the kind of
progress that lets you say we actually
know stuff
so it makes much more sense to base our
argument on economics than our argument
on philosophy and in fact if you look at
the people who do it you find that
although not all economists are
libertarian and quite a lot of them are
not anarchists oddly enough nonetheless
among academics the economists are the
ones who are most likely to be
sympathetic to our views and the
philosophers with the exception of of
Michael humer those who are least likely
to so I think there is some evidence
that economics is a better way of
persuading people than than philosophy
is so to summarize my argument
it is that the nap as usually understood
has implications that nobody agrees with
it is that if you take a weaker form of
the nap such as minimizing coercion or
compensating people when you violate
their rights it does not solve the
problems and in particular no longer
makes good Arguments for libertarianism
because you're now thrown back on
consequentialist arguments about what
policies will or will not violate more
rights than others
uh and furthermore that there is no way
to derive the nap just as there is no
way to derive anybody else's moral
principles that I can see uh
that furthermore we do not need the nap
because libertarianism is enough better
than the Alternatives so that is better
in terms of the values that most people
already have
and that if you want to persuade people
showing them that a minimum wage will
hurt poor people by pricing them out of
the market with the result that many of
them are unemployed and never take the
first step up the ladder that leads to a
better life is a whole lot better salute
better tactic than saying well you can't
use the uh you you can't impose the
minimum wage law because imposing a
minimum wage law will violate the rights
of the employee and the employer to make
whatever contract they want so that's my
basic argument and I will give my
opponent the 55 seconds that are still
left thank you
thank you
excellent thank you
[Applause]
now to establish the case for the
negative of the resolution is Gene
Epstein
[Applause]
uh thanks
uh
yeah everybody can hear me yeah okay uh
in a forthcoming biography of the
brilliant Economist Milton Friedman we
learn about the daily debates Milton
conducted with his wife and kids
according to the book Milton's son David
recalls that he was quote a senior in
high school before he realized that
there were forms of conversation other
than argument
uh
well
while debates usually persisted across
dinners the book continues the family
relied on a numerical code to establish
clear
victories
a declaration of two stood for your
right I was wrong close quote
needless to say David will make my day
if he flashes me a two once we conclude
our debate
but I certainly don't expect such an
outcome against an opponent with that
kind of training
but I do wonder if the Friedman family
ever debated today's topic
so if so I'm going to guess that Milton
took my position
consider what Milton once said about the
War on Drugs quote
the major basis for my opposition to the
War on Drugs has not been that it's
produced a lot more harm than good
it's been primarily a moral view I do
not believe the state has any more right
to tell me what can come out of my what
I can what to put in my mouth and then
it has to tell me what can come out of
my mouth
these two are essentially the same thing
and they are both essential elements of
Freedom close quote
so in making his case against the
government's War on Drugs Milton was
forthrightly stating his belief in the
centrality of the non-aggression
principle or what I prefer to call the
zero aggression principle or zap after
libertarian philosopher Gerard Casey as
Casey puts it no one whether
individually or as a member of a group
May initiate or threaten to initiate the
use of physical violence or aggression
against the person or property of
another close quote
the War on Drugs is the state
threatening aggression against us if we
dare to exercise our right to put
certain chemicals in our bodies by
viewing the freedom argument a central
Milton wasn't ignoring the arguments
that the War on Drugs also does far more
harm than good rather he was placing the
burden of proof where it belongs on
those who would defend the idea of
putting people in a cage for doing
something that could harm nobody but
themselves
now take the consequentialist case that
David would make Defenders of the
government's War on Drugs have a much
easier time responding to it they can
logically object that a world in which
all drugs are completely legal is a
world that does not as yet exist and
since it doesn't exist we Libertarians
can't rule out the danger that drug
addiction will become so common it will
tear at the fabric of society
the only effective way to respond to
that point is to invoke Milton's moral
argument the burden of proof is not on
us Libertarians to argue that our
society could survive full legalization
of drugs the burden is on them to prove
that it will lead to horrific outcomes
and since they're talking about a world
that does not as yet exist it's a burden
that can't sustain
in this case then David would have us
believe that the right way to persuade
people of the libertarian solution to
the government's War on Drugs is by
showing them that the outcomes of full
legalization are superior without any
resort to the flawed non-aggression
principle my point by contrast is that
not only does it greatly help to cite
the zero aggression principle when
making this argument it's often
essential another example
the libertarian case for free trade no
one has done a better job than David in
explaining the economic gains from trade
he asks us to consider two ways to make
cars
build them in a domestic Factory or grow
them in the form of wheat
do it the second way shift the week to
Japan and a few months later ships
appear loaded with Toyotas that's a way
of convincing people about the benefits
of trade by pointing to a positive
outcome
but it doesn't address a key objection
raised by Economist Russ Roberts
you start to make the case for free
trade Russ Roberts observed in a recent
interview and people are saying right
but the folks who are left behind their
lives aren't meaningful anymore
and you respond oh but look at the gains
from trade
that's the way the economist deals with
the fact that sometimes Imports are hard
for people I think the economist view is
really bad close quote
the problem then is that David's
argument doesn't directly address Russ
Roberts objection when you allow Imports
of Toyotas to destroy jobs along with
the communities in which those job
holders live the lives of those affected
aren't meaningful anymore
the only way to respond is by asking
what right does the government have to
penalize me for using my money to buy
imported goods or services that I freely
choose to buy if domestic workers want
to keep want to keep my business they
are perfectly free to lower their prices
to lower their wages while getting their
firms to lower their prices
and domestic workers and their
supporters are quite free to create a
buy American shopping website that
patronizes only domestic firms on the
grounds that many Americans lives will
otherwise lose their meaning
that domestic shopping website might
attract a lot of followers for many
years after World War II Jews boycotted
German cars even though the cars offered
Great Value my own father participated
in that silent boycott and then later he
would buy only us-made cars for
patriotic reasons my father did all this
voluntarily the government had no right
to coerce him into buying American-made
cars if he preferred to buy cars from
abroad
so in making the case for free trade not
only does it greatly help to cite the
zero aggression principle it's often
essential
that's because no consequentialist case
for radical reform made by a Libertarian
can ever be completely sufficient the
consequentialist case is usually
important but we also need to invoke the
zero aggression principle to establish
the point that our default position is
always in favor of freedom and free
choice and the burden of proof is always
on those who would restrict our freedom
and free choice I could apply this same
argument to many other aspects of the
libertarian case from gun rights to
legalizing sex work to preventing the
waging of War
but in the time remaining I want to
focus on the other key point in David's
argument that the zero aggression
principle or zap is in some crucial way
a flawed principle
David makes several key points against
the zap in his book The Machinery of
Freedom one is that quote Libertarians
have not yet produced any proof that our
moral position is correct since quote
lots of people are in favor of
initiating coercion
one possible response to such people as
proposed by philosopher Gerard Casey is
that if they reject the zero aggression
principle they logically open themselves
up to the risk that that someone else
will initiate aggression against them
and then they'll have no principled
grounds on which to reject such
aggression
and while many authoritarians won't be
impressed by this argument I don't see
why we should be the least bit impressed
in return some might reject the idea
that murder is a crime but that doesn't
mean we have to agree with them
here's another of David's arguments when
it comes to aggression against someone's
property it's impossible to draw the
line at what does and does not
constitute such aggression quote if I
fire a thousand megawatt laser beam at
your front door I am surely violating
your property David writes but what if I
reduce the intensity of the brightness
of a to a flashlight or to it or to turn
on my light in a house or strike a match
David then comments the obvious response
is that only significant violations of
my property rights count but then he
clinches the argument with the challenge
but who decides what is significant
but doesn't David's challenge of where
to draw the line apply to a whole range
of cases most of us subscribe to
including David himself
take the law against assault and battery
if someone extends his hand to you for a
handshake and then breaks the bones of
your hand that painful injury would
surely justify an actionable claim
but what if someone merely gives you a
firm handshake if people with merely
firm handshakes were getting indicted
for assault and battery would David
argue that we have to uh we have to
regard the assault and battery as
potentially discardable and flawed and
full of holes those those there are
those who claim to feel battered if
someone makes an innocuous remark that
they decide to take personally and there
have been Co-op buildings in Manhattan
with smoking tobacco in your apartment
was forbidden even with your doors and
windows closed on the bizarre grounds
that you might seriously infect your
neighbors in order in in other
apartments with second-hand smoke so
maybe we'll soon have neighbors charging
you with aggression if you turn on the
lights in your house the very danger
David warns against excuse me okay
but we can only hope to live in a same
Society where reasonable people
adjudicate such matters reasonably and
sanely it doesn't mean we discard the
zero aggression principle
David's other objection involves cases
in which someone commits aggression in
extenuating circumstances one of David's
favorite cases involves your neighbor
falling from his balcony and grabbing a
flagpole on your balcony in order to
break his fall
that person is clearly trespassed on
your property if my balcony had been
invaded in this way I would only be
happy that my neighbor wasn't injured
while marketing marveling at his
physical dexterity but but if others did
bring charges of trespass the Intruder
would have to plead guilty because the
zero aggression principle is an absolute
principle that is always actionable
always actionable always absolute but
then there's the question of punishment
the Intruder would be well advised to
plead from Mercy on the ground that he
meant no harm and was only trying to
save his own life
or suppose quote suppose you happen to
know that everyone in the world is going
to die tomorrow by some natural
catastrophe rights David further suppose
that the only way to prevent it involves
stealing a piece of equipment worth a
hundred dollars from someone who
rightfully owns it close quote do you
steal the equipment and save the world I
certainly would after my crime was
committed I would I would explain to the
owner of the equipment the reason for my
theft if he still bought charges against
me I would be forced to admit my guilt
so there is never any question that in
all of these cases aggression as against
property has occurred and is therefore
an actionable offense it is an absolute
principle always applied absolutely the
separate question is the penalty imposed
at my trial I would ask that an imposing
punishment those who judge me take into
account that I was saving everyone in
the world from Extinction
another example from David so quote
suppose we are threatened with military
conquest by a particularly vicious
totalitarian government if the conquest
is successful we will lose most of our
freedom and many of us will lose our
lives close quote under the
circumstances David wouldn't we favor
forced conscription to raise an army
even though conscription is slavery and
therefore never Justified as David
writes isn't temporary slavery better
than the permanent slavery of
totalitarian rule I would still be
against conscription first of course
conscription would only be necessary if
we couldn't get enough volunteers to
resist the Invader and enough folks
voluntarily offering the money to back
these volunteers but who was to say
before the fact that an army of possibly
reluctant conscripts would be victorious
Against The Invader we'd then be
choosing temporary slavery without
necessarily avoiding the permanent
slavery that David warns against but
then who's to say that the slavery would
be permanent as Murray rothbart has
pointed out the main reason a conquering
country can rule a defeated country is
that the latter has an existing state
apparatus to transmit and enforce the
Victor's orders onto a subject
population close quote no such apparatus
would exist in a Libertarian Society
instead as rothbud also points out the
occupiers would likely be confront
confronted by resistance Fighters whose
persistence could eventually Drive The
Victors out such things have happened in
the past
in his 1973 book The Machinery of
Freedom David wrote I believe that
everyone has a right to run his own life
to go to hell in his own fashion close
quote the right to go to hell in one's
own fashion without interference from
the state or from others is in fact the
essence of the zero aggression principle
stated in audacious terms getting back
to those legendary debates at Friedman
family dinners did David think of that
great line In the Heat of debate and
save it for the book he would eventually
write
I like to imagine he did thanks
[Applause]
seven and a half minutes okay seven
minutes
so David now has seven and a half
minutes to rebut
I was hoping that when Gene started out
by telling you about our family code
number two that the next thing he was
going to say was number two and that
would then end the the debate but
apparently not he's he's mistaken about
our debates in a number of ways to begin
with uh while my father certainly made
moral arguments as I did and do he did
not put them in terms of the absolute
nap for presumably the sort of reasons
that I've discussed he in fact was in
favor of Taxation uh he was one of the
things we ended up disagreeing about was
whether or not you should have an
anarchist society and his position was
that the system I described might work
but probably wouldn't my position was
that it might not work but probably
would I devoted chapter of the Third
Edition of Machinery to discussing ways
in which it might break down
that was the consequentialist
disagreement he did not at any point say
but in order to have my limited or did I
say in order to have this uh limited
State you've got to have Taxation and
Taxation uh is is immoral uh so in fact
my father was not an anarchist and I was
um
and in fact uh as Gene might have
deduced from looking at the first
edition of the Machinery of Freedom
which was written in about 1970 I think
it was published in 72 as I remember I
was indeed more fond of moral arguments
than than now so that my guess is that
in our arguments I probably often used
moral arguments though not put as
explicitly as the nap back then I should
say lest you
overestimate just how I was in
understanding a conversation I did enter
my senior year in high school when I was
15. but
with regard to Gene's response uh with
regard to the War on Drugs it is
certainly true that we cannot prove that
abolishing the War on Drugs would have
good effects you cannot prove that
continuing the War on Drugs has good
effects you can't even say it has
observable effects now but next year is
going to be different every year is
different unfortunately there are very
few things one can prove in this world
what has to be satisfied with the best
arguments one can offer reasons to
believe something is true not proofs
that something that something is true
with regard to Russ Roberts argument
which I haven't read but I've just
gotten from Gene I do not claim that my
story about growing Hondas proves that
tariffs are bad
what it does is to prove that some
arguments for tariffs are bad it shows
that the trade-off is not between the
welfare of American Auto Workers and
Japanese Auto Workers which is the way
most people who support tariffs imagine
it but rather between the welfare of
American Auto Workers and American
farmers
well American farmers can also have
their way of life destroyed by an
insufficient demand for what they are
doing uh
but in general I don't think one can
prove in a sense of establishing 100
probability that uh libertarian Society
is better uh all one can do is to show
good reasons to believe it is better and
that's the best that one that one can
ever do uh I was sort of puzzled by
Gene's argument that you shouldn't
accept that you should accept the nap
because if you don't accept the nap
then you might be at at risk of having
people coerce you I presume that lots of
you do accept the nap and nonetheless
you get coerced that there seems to be a
bizarre logic in which you suppose if I
believe something that forces everybody
who interacts with me to believe to
believe it it isn't true so that's not
in fact an argument for believing uh in
in the nap I noticed that Gene on his
Express principles has to approve of
eminent domain because he has told us
that it is all right to violate people's
property rights provided you're willing
to Bear the the cost that results in in
eminent domain we have a legal process
it's not a jury trial as it happens but
a legal process for determining how much
the government owes you for the property
that it's seized and that seems to be
his view of how you how you settle uh
such uh such questions
uh
the
yeah I want to go back to the fact that
as I think I made clear yesterday my
Arguments for Anna here are not claimed
proofs my favorite online writer Scott
Alexander ended his review of Machinery
of Freedom with the comment that he
hoped my system would be tried somewhere
far from him he was right
I think it's better but obviously better
if somebody else tries it and if it
doesn't work that doesn't affect me and
if it does work then I can imitate it
then we live in a world of uncertainty
even if we like to pretend we don't that
one of the things that I find irritating
here is the number of people who are
absolutely 100 certain who are the bad
guys who are the good guys what's right
what's wrong we don't live in that world
we live in a world where the best you
can do is to look at the arguments look
at the evidence and reach conclusions uh
now I should say I am not arguing that
you should never make moral arguments
clearly rhetorically moral arguments
sometimes persuade people because
sometimes people share some of your
moral beliefs as well as some of your
consequential beliefs but what I don't
think people share if they think about
it is the strong form of the libertarian
preferred moral belief which is the nap
because as I've pointed out it leads to
conclusions that none of us really
believe in and you don't solve the
problem by saying well it's actually all
right to initiate queries you just have
to pay for it which as far as I can tell
is is Gene's gain solution do it uh
I think that's most of what I wanted to
say
let me
let me point out
some evidence that I've observed about
people disagreeing Less in even their
moral beliefs than they think they do
that if you argue with a socialist about
the whether or not
property owners are allowed to own
property it rapidly turns out that your
imaginary story for the poor guy and the
rich guy is very different from his that
in his about in your imaginary Story the
rich guy spent his resources hacking
down the jungle to plant a field while
the poor guy sat there watching in the
Socialist view the poor guy hacked out
the field and then the rich guy stole it
from him and I think that suggests that
there is more common even in the
underlying moral intuitions let alone
the underlying beliefs of what people
want so I think I've made made my
argument we're going to have some time
for you people to ask questions and we
will see what Eugene what Gene's
rebuttal is
foreign
[Applause]
we will very soon be going to uh
question and answer so I'd like you guys
to be thinking of questions for both the
affirmative and the negative and I'll be
taking those in session but to rebut for
the negative is gene
I I was looking forward to getting a
fuller story and getting corrected by
David about my little mention about
Milton Friedman I love that passage in
the book that has actually not yet been
released but my son read it in
pre-release and showed me that passage
which I really loved and in fact as a
columnist at Barron's I interviewed
Milton Friedman and two or three times a
year I would call him up just for a chat
in fact I spoke with them about a month
before he died and uh that was one of
the great pleasures of my life and so I
wanted to provoke some reminiscence
about Milton everything Milton's David
said about Milton is true I concede that
completely he knew him better than I
even though I had the pleasure of
getting to know him as a columnist at
Barons but let me just read to you what
David just said which is essentially
what I'm trying to say there are very
few things one can prove in this World
indeed
obviously the fact that you and we can
prove a few things you guys are sitting
here very few things one can prove in
this world and that's the reason why
David's powerful consequentialist
arguments part of which I enlisted need
the grounding of what I again prefer to
call the zero aggression principle
precisely because there are very few
things we can prove in this world we
need to tell people I have met who
fantasize that ninety percent of the
country is going to get drunk on drugs
and the other 10 percent is going to
starve Again David mentioned Russ
Roberts but didn't speak to his concern
Russ is now an economist he's Pro he
prefers to talk about human feeling we
talk we do look at communities that got
broken up by free trade and all the rest
of it and Russ says oh the gains from
trade it's pathetic we can't talk about
that look at those people who suffered
so my point is to ground it in the zero
aggression principle but then also
recognize that that people in terms of
their purchases always often feel got
compassion for others they're that the
the idea that people would buy American
and periodic reason my own father did it
the point is that that once we grounded
in the zero aggression principle then we
can understand these things
David mentioned eminent domain and but
of course I'm not for it the burden of
proof is someone who take your property
by the way I don't know if Dave is in
love with the Chicago thesis the Chicago
guys have it wrong if if your property
the austrians teach us that this that at
all value is subjected that for the
government to give you the market price
for your property well what if you're
what if your ancestors are buried on
that property no I wouldn't accept 10
million dollars for property that you
think is worth a hundred thousand
dollars of course you don't advocate
property rights so the burden of proof
is on someone who can prove to us the
unprovable that in some in this world
where eminent domain is permitted that
you can somehow bring about such
overwhelming you can somehow avoid human
catastrophe and it's all ridiculous of
course I'm not against eminent domain
for precisely the same reason grounded
and what David feels we can conveniently
ignore the zero aggression principle you
don't take people's property and and the
idea that you can give it to them with
just come that's crazy there is no such
thing they don't want to sell you that
property period full stop do something
else with your life rather than take my
property forcibly let me introduce
another example since well what else did
David mention the moral logic well no
indeed I agreed that ultimately I could
say to somebody who who doesn't care
about aggression that to say well you
know you won't have a logical defense if
somebody agrees is against you but of
course as I conceded and as David
pointed out they can reject my ideal
might mix right I don't give I'll just
beat up anybody who tries to regret of
course there are people in this world
who simply will not be convinced about
our belief in the zero aggression
principle and I'm certainly not enough
of a philosopher to invoke all the
fundamental reasons why I believe in it
I just think it's as natural as
breathing as some of the rest of you
probably think so indeed if David wants
to say well it's only as natural as
breathing you're just a shallow
philosopher David will be absolutely
right but but but the next part war is
an important issue because by the way
what what do I hear all the time well
well if we'd only stayed there for
another two or three years we finally
would have won we got out of Afghanistan
after 20 years another five years if we
hadn't been so craving we finally would
have won there's never enough war in
killing but for these people who have
this religious faith I don't know if I
can convince them but I can only tell
them and David apparently can't that
you're going to kill more people and
don't you think the burden of proof is
on you and and that is a burden you
cannot sustain because we've had 20
years of killing or 10 years of killing
and we haven't gotten anywhere so again
we can't leave home without it precisely
because of David's point we can only
martial our data all of it necessary all
of it important I'm not a philosopher I
was economic Scholars of Barons for for
26 years I was trained in economics and
in the Austrian school which I think is
more worthwhile because again it it you
know I I my namesake Richard Epstein
will talk about well the government can
always give somebody with them in the
domain the right amount of money I I
don't know maybe I don't know if Milton
felt that way I never asked him about
him in a domain but but certainly uh
maybe you would have said that but
that's ridiculous from an Austrian
standpoint all value is subjective
doesn't want to sell he doesn't want to
sell no price is good enough I guess I
want to end on my best moment with
Milton Milton was inveying against the
war on drugs and indeed he was talking
consequentially he mentioned a point
about crime in the in the in the four
quarters of the country because of the
war on drugs and I said I didn't know
that I didn't know that I said to him
and Milton said to me if you don't know
that you really are very ignorant and
and that that was my favorite moment
with Milton we all are very ignorant of
the world we all have to cope with the
facts of the world in an ignorant way
just like David has to we can only
Marshal our arguments we can never prove
things in this world we need the zero
aggression principle to recognize where
the burden of proof lies and is in all
of these cases the other side cannot
bear that burden thanks
foreign
[Applause]
we will now be going over to the
question and answer I'd like people to
be having questions for both the
affirmative and the negative one at a
time and I'll be transferring but I will
take the moderators prerogative and I
will ask the first questions uh the
question I have for the affirmative uh
there is David the Socialist calculation
problem there's also the
consequentialist uh calculation problem
that the number of outcomes of any
particular action are actually infinite
they are primary and secondary and
tertiary and out at infant item and that
for each at each possible action there
would be values that would be placed by
each and every individual each person
living and people living in the future
that we would have to calculate and then
eventually once we get infinity by
Infinity we would then have to combine
these all into a single consequence and
say therefore we go and and go don't go
don't we need some sort of Bedrock if
our goal isn't just to uh employ
economics professors
if your argument is that the
consequences sorry if your argument is
that the consequences of Acts are not
knowable for certain that's true but if
you really believe that that prevents
reaching conclusions I don't know how
you take any actions at all you don't
even know whether feeding Ron Paul who I
was hoping was actually going to be
moderating because he's much handsomer
than Dennis
for all you know the result of feeding
Ron Paul is that he will get sufficient
energy to bite somebody and kill them
you can't be sure it isn't true but in
the real world the way we deal with
individual choices and choices among
societies we want is by doing our best
to figure out what will happen knowing
that we might be wrong that's that's the
world we live in I I you know I want to
comment on David's answer I should have
told you in advance if somebody gives a
uh speaking to live a microphone please
sorry yeah okay I just want to remind
you as moderator as when I moderate a
question is asked of one person the
other person gets to comment of course
of course of course David is right that
clearly as we Libertarians like to
emphasize most of life is not a
Libertarian problem in most cases uh we
entrepreneurs act on hunches
entrepreneurs take risks that they have
to deal with the facts they know as well
as their creative notion about where the
future lies I'm
I'm restricting myself to the
libertarian arguments which are narrowly
focused on the predations of government
or the predictions of others it's a
narrow field that's where the zero
aggression pencil becomes crucial and
important that's where it applies but
not to most of life as I imagine most of
you already know
yeah so let me ask uh of the negative
most people upon hearing the
non-aggression principle would say yes
that's very uh very true I I kind of
feel that but
there's really not really aggression
there's really not force most people
will comply and I am so concerned about
this particular outcome for this
particular segment that I'm willing to
go ahead and ignore uh the uh the
possible theoretical uh initiation of
violence with uh uh in order to help
this particular segment well absolutely
it is possible that even if I tell
people who are quite prepared to put you
and me in a cage for you if you're using
certain substances even if I tell them
that you bear a very heavy burden of
proof to show that it would be
disastrous in this unknown World for for
there to be 90 for for their uh to be
legal and full legalization of drugs
even if I tell them that and I can't
convince them then I guess I have to
give up I'm only talking about at least
doing my best to offer them the right
argument I if I want to tell Russ
Roberts that as much as you weep for the
people whose lives are meaningless are
you really going to impose government's
solution to impose penalties on the rest
of us including poor people who want to
buy what they want to buy from abroad
are you really still willing to do that
yes I am well I can't convince them
ultimately but at least I've given him
the best argument possible
Milton uh David you could
do you want to comment on that or no I'm
I want to take questions from the
audience so uh the first question for
the affirmative
okay
you can ask any question he wants from
anybody
um
question is for both using the guy
falling out of the building grabbing on
to the flagpole
let's say somehow that flag it causes
serious property damage let's say ten
thousand dollars
would you say that the person who fell
then is liable for the
for the repairs sure
yes
well if you certainly if you again my my
point I want to stress is that all of
these violations of the zero aggression
principle again as I prefer to call it
zero is better than none uh is that uh
they're always an absolutely actionable
uh and uh if if I if I own the balcony
and this incredible Daredevil managed to
save his life by grabbing the flagpole I
might I might just settle at five
thousand and solve the rest because I'd
just be astonished by the story of what
he did but so therefore the the penalty
and what actually happens in real life
is a completely separate question the
violation is there but indeed certainly
uh if I were a different kind of person
I might say well you know ten thousand
Earth well dollars worth plus a five you
owe me eleven thousand you owe me twelve
thousand very possibly sure that could
be imposed yeah
Gene could you push that mic upstairs
yeah there that's good uh next question
uh this question is for the negative and
it might touch on what you were just
saying uh a little bit Yeah and please
do uh either of you uh correct me if any
of my characterizations here are
incorrect sure
um in response to David's Point related
to the Continuum problem of casting
photons at someone without permission oh
you know whether the megawatt laser or
the match yeah yeah
um you raise the existence of similar or
Continuum problems such as handshake
grip and essentially said that we don't
really have a problem resolving that so
this sort of problem is not
insurmountable but he's in the question
not whether or not they are
insurmountable but insurmountable using
the zero aggression Principle as a basis
that is how does the non-aggression
principle or zero aggression principle
actually tell us what the proper grip is
or verify that such a grip was used or
communicate that information beforehand
to either party don't our methods of
resolving those questions necessarily
reduce
to constructing answers on grounds that
are at least partially consequences
consequentialist or reliant on external
principles
um well I I that's a good question and
uh the there's no question that in the
examples I cited that we face that
problem right now in this Society right
now again a co-op will say windows
closed doors closed but there's
secondhand smoke so some of my
imagination I say something to you that
that says that you know whatever I might
say that's uh glancing or whatever it
might be it's actionable so therefore
there's no question that or or take take
the issue of murder if you were involved
in some causal way with the death of
another person there's always it's
always actionable but Society faces
judgment calls in difficult cases having
to do with where you negligent in
driving the truck that hit that person
if you if you're tired but went out and
that person was accidentally hit to what
extent are you responsible well the jury
would have to look at to what extent did
you have new tires
Society is constantly faced at the
margin with difficult cases in
establishing and applying every
principle including in my example the
example of murder so therefore I would
say that and again in applying the zero
aggression principle just as in the case
of murder or assault or any of those
other cases the light or the rest of it
that we Face these problems all the time
but but we don't we don't say well the
absolute rule against murder is absolute
however we we do have to recognize the
problems in applying it in in difficult
cases intent first degree murder all of
those problems come up all the time but
we don't repudiate the absolute rule
against so many of these cases as in the
case of assault murder or in the case of
of the light or the beam you have to
apply your reasonable standards of
society to these principles so if your
point is is it does the zero aggression
principle inform your judgment well it
does inform your judgment in that
clearly you recognize that there's a
potential for for aggression here but
admittedly as in the case of murder or
all the rest of it your judgment has to
be informed by the Norms of society and
by what people regard as sane and
sensible that's the best answer I can
get I don't see that we repudiate the
zero principle principle because of
these difficult cases any more than we
repudiate all the other cases that
arrive in society that arise in society
today let me comment on that because in
fact in Machinery of freedom I follow
that point with a chapter on economic
analysis of law and the economic
analysis of law which is the central
part of Economics that I've been doing
in recent decades is an attempt to
figure figure out what the rules ought
to be if what you want to do is to
maximize economic efficiency I don't
think we have a good way of knowing how
to maximize individual liberty that be a
good thing if you could but economic
efficiency which is some sort of a way
an imperfect way of adding up how well
everybody else is everybody is is the
best we've got at this point and one can
in fact use economics to analyze
questions such as what should the
penalty for a crime be what counts as a
crime and so forth you can't do anything
like a perfect job of it because we
don't have enough information but if
people are actually curious about how
you would approach that problem one of
my other books is called Law's order
you can read that on my web page like
most of my things you can read on my web
page and that sketches out how you would
approach questions such as light bulb
versus a laser beam from the standpoint
of economics
hello
the examples so far have focused on the
consequence for the violation of the
aggression principle and I I don't think
we're looking for an abdication of
responsibility but I wondered about an
example that looked more at the efficacy
of the non-aggression principle in the
argument for example I teach school and
there has certainly been a lot of
coercion to get a vaccine lately for
which I will not comply nor has my
Administration made me feel like I
needed to thankfully though I was never
in a position where I would have but for
many people I've said to them what are
you willing to do to vaccinate me
because you would have to pin me down
and give it to me forcibly with me
fighting the entire time so what are you
willing to do to force my compliance and
I wondered what would be your argument
absent the non-aggression principle that
would be as effective in that realm
thank you I guess my basic argument
would be that having institutions that
let people coerce other people is much
more likely to result in coercing them
in ways that make the world worse than
in ways that make the world better that
if we could have a government that is a
dictatorship by a perfectly wise
benevolent despot what I like to refer
to as a bureaucrat God
uh who knew everything in your Utopia
but we get that's how we convince them
that in that world
indeed
you could improve on the outcomes of
Freedom that in that world the perfectly
wise benevolent death but could realize
that you would be better off uh with uh
getting vaccinated and would you know
take some convenient occasion to put you
unconscious and vaccinate you and maybe
not even tell you because why upset you
about it but we don't live in that world
we live in a world where all of the
decisions are being made by human beings
the human beings are making them not
only with imperfect information but with
the wrong incentives that each each
human being has an incentive to serve
his own interests and those of people he
cares about the nice thing about the
market is that it's a way of getting
socially desirable outcomes out of
individual selfishness the political
Market doesn't do that if you work out
the what public Choice theory is the
branch of Economics that deals with it
if you work out what the implications of
public Choice Theory are you end up with
a whole bunch of cases where people are
forced to do things that make the world
worse that the U.S is currently turning
into alcohol 10 percent of the world's
supply of the largest source of food in
the world namely maize
we are doing it on the claim that that
will reduce CO2 output despite the fact
that everybody involved including Al
Gore conceded years ago that it doesn't
reduce uh CO2 output it does however
raise the income of farmers and Farmers
vote
so the basic argument that I would make
is not that there is nothing one can
imagine a government doing or an
individual doing that violates rights
that would be a good thing but only that
institutions that allow you to violate
rights will usually have bad
consequences
um I was hoping that that was was the
moderator I was expecting to have but
unfortunately Ron Paul doesn't seem to
be uh doing it here my my only comment
is that every once in a while when I
talk to people about the idea of
vaccines I just Begin by pointing out to
them and every once in a while they find
it so much compelling to contemplate to
contemplate the point that if if the
government is forcing you to put a
chemical in your body that you don't
want to put in your body that's an
offense of the zero aggression principle
that's an act a very very serious
aggression and the default position is
no such thing should happen and if you
want to voluntarily use the vaccine fine
and and usually amazingly some people
are convinced by that argument what a
voluntarily use the vaccine fine nobody
has a right to force you into doing it
and that's one once again the zero
aggression principle hopefully
simplifying the issue unfortunately that
argument doesn't really work because the
people on the other side will tell you
that by getting the disease you are
going to be aggressing against the
people who catch it from you I know and
that therefore they are entitled to
force you to do what will keep you from
getting the disease since David
responded to my response let me respond
to his response of of course of course
that's going to be the argument and of
course that argument is also ridiculous
as David probably knows himself the only
point is to say again that indeed if if
if you're going to kill a a 50 people by
not taking the the vaccine maybe this
some kind of argument for that because
the because the aggression is going to
be far greater the burden of proof is on
you give us the evidence for that
ridiculous claim and we know of course
that it was ridiculous in the case of
this vaccine that's the whole point it
did make that well I'm sorry people did
make it of course they did of course
they of course of course of course they
did but give us and that is and that is
a consequentialist question not a moral
question but the burden morally is on
you to make your argument the default
position is leave me alone that's the
whole point yeah yeah next
yeah
this question is for the this this
question is for the affirmative and it
uh builds off the previous question uh
suppose that there was some hypothetical
virus where the evidence was bearing out
that uh if you lock down the population
fewer people would die from it obviously
not coveted as we all know but for the
sake of the question supposedly it's
hypothetical and suppose he were
discussing a lockdown policy with
somebody whose stated objective uh was
to minimize deaths from the virus which
a lot of people who were advocating for
lockdowns during covid that's what they
were saying that they wanted how would
you go about demonstrating that they
should not want lockdowns by their own
standards I would point out to them that
life is that that minimizing deaths is
not in fact the only thing they care
about that it would be pretty easy to
point out to somebody that if you could
reduce deaths by one by uh putting
everybody in prison for the years it
would not be desirable to do that and
they will then presumably realize that
there are a whole lot of costs and
benefits to trade off and not just one
uh a going back a step you would want if
you are making the argument today you
would want to say look
in giving the government the power to do
lockdowns you are taking it for granted
the government will only do it when it's
a good idea but we happen to have some
evidence on this subject Sweden didn't
know lockdowns at all ended up doing
probably a little bit better on excess
mortality than most of the other
countries though not all of the
countries there is very little evidence
that the lockdowns did any good and that
ought to make you conclude too late to
change that one but you ought to make
you very suspicious of the government
having the power to do something because
you can observe that the government will
not in fact restrict itself to doing
that something only when it's a good
idea well let me comment also in this
way which partly responsible David said
earlier
you might say this is kind of
unfortunate like blend between my view
and David's I think David's
consequentialist arguments are basically
very sound and I I Look to Him to help
us out with a consequentialist issues
and that's been my focus as an an
economist so indeed I I grant in
principle that if there's just some
overwhelming disaster which is which
would be aggression against others there
there there's going to be massive deaths
that that could conceivably be some kind
of argument and for lockdowns but of
course as as David pointed out and as I
would say take the states and Nations
that have strict lockdowns those that
had very relatively loose the outcomes
of virtually indistinguishable the
lockdowns achieve nothing the lockdowns
however did a lot of harm but my only
point then is that if David wants to
point out to me but but you start
talking consequentially yourself I mean
I'm going to agree with that I'm going
to agree that this some argument in
principle Between Heaven and Earth that
you could make that if that if 90 of the
population is going to die and the rest
of us are probably going to die for
starvation if we don't do something or
other then that's that's immense
aggression against others that we might
need to avoid to choose the other
favorite example in keeping with what
David was saying we we we should impose
a five mile an hour speed limit on
drivers now that would probably cause a
lot of deaths anyway but uh but
obviously that would mean that would
reduce deaths on the highway so indeed
we have the bias in in favor of freedom
and that's my only point that
consequentialism matters but but the
zero aggression principle is a central
indispensable part of it I have a
question for Gene yeah okay and that is
you said that if if a violate a parent
violation of Rights prevented massive
violation of Rights then it's all right
what if it prevents massive costs that
are not violations of Rights the point
of my asteroid example originally is
that an asteroid hitting Earth and
killing everybody is not a rights
violation it's a catastrophe but a non
non-rights violation catastrophe my own
view in terms of my moral position is
that violating rights is a bad thing but
not the only bad thing and therefore it
is legitimate to violate rights if you
get very large benefits in terms of
other values and so the question is if
if the only way of preventing a
catastrophe which is not a rights
violation merely kills millions of
people is to violate somebody's rights
are you in favor of doing it yeah well I
I thought I addressed that in in that
your example about the totalitarian
government's attacking I I simply cannot
believe that in a Libertarian Society uh
that that would that people would be so
stupid as not to organize some hacking
way to quell the asteroid I would not be
bothered about about the lack of
authority but that's a consequentialist
claim if you're making an argument of
principle you ought to be able to apply
the argument under any circumstances not
just under the circumstances you've
chosen well okay I I guess I know I I
guess I guess I think I think you you
certainly make the point in the extreme
that it's that it's conceivable but I I
don't think it's I don't think in this
world it could ever happen that I guess
I guess that's my when you're talking
about the totalitarian government attack
the asteroid you mean people are so damn
stupid that they don't know the
estimates come and won't do anything we
we need the wise government to impose
some kind of standard but in your
Anarchist Society there won't be such a
government right so what what that
wasn't a government an argument for a
wise government that was an argument for
an individual stealing something in
order to stop oh okay stealing something
oh yeah no no that's a crime no no
that's actionable no no no in that
particular case that particularly I
steal something to avoid the asteroid
indeed I should be indicted absolutely
but you should do it yes therefore you
should violate violate somebody's rights
you should initiate coercion which
violates the nap that's the point I've
been making well super I'm sorry I would
be guilty of the crime yeah sure
excuse me I I I guess now we get into a
brilliant moment of
I committed a crime and I'm a criminal
and I'm absolutely reliable for the
crime it all it absolutely applies to me
I'm a criminal and I should stand trial
for that criminal crime so it's always
an absolutely a crime that's all and
that sometimes you should commit crimes
so sometimes you should violate right
sometimes I will commit crimes that's
all because because I'm an immoral
person I guess
okay I'm I'm gonna actually exercise a
little bit of moderation yeah enough uh
take another question from the audience
hold on uh uh you asked the question of
Gene Gene do you have a question of
Milton
I'm so sorry right all right
Milton would be 111 years old if he were
here today he was born in 1912. uh no I
don't have any questions for David
what's the next question yeah
yeah hi um you've covered this a little
bit but I'll put a little finer point on
it I'm wondering if the resolution
itself has a little bit of circularity
to it if we're saying that we don't need
the nap to defend libertarianism
um most of us Define libertarianism as
as uh no one gets a special pass to take
my stuff which is sort of another way to
say the nap like so so what is then
libertarianism or is it just as I think
I've heard merely an infinite array of
consequentially optimal policy choices
or decisions anytime two people interact
there's a chance for conflict so how
does that get solved if not uh appealing
to some deontological principle
um are we just making every judge a
consequentialist calculator and how do
we know that they won't calculate wrong
well and the vet mate look again
libertarianism is I imagine most of you
know it's not a philosophy of life it it
simply it's simply a key principle that
that tends to inform for the most part
our attitudes toward government is
simply the zero aggression Principle as
I enunciated it's got very narrow
implications except of course when
governments start running amok and uh
and and then and while David and I could
acknowledge marginal cases in which the
juries have to decide rather difficult
situations for the most part the laws
against theft murder and all the rest of
it are very clear and very easy to apply
so I don't think but but there's no
question that in the jury or in the case
that David cited by the way when he
talks about the economics of punishment
the fact of the matter is that in many
societies I think even including this
one if you're a murderer and you're your
a torturer there is a certain attitude
on the part of society that economics is
not the only issue but retribution is
punishment just simple retribution for
your heinous crime that could enter his
own well but if you're saying that that
in any society the application of law is
complex having you're absolutely right
but the zero question is it full stop
nothing else right and I guess I was
more directing my question to Dr
Friedman as to how then he defines
libertarianism without reference to
property rights yeah I don't
I don't think there is a bright line
definition by which you can say so and
so is a Libertarian so and so isn't uh I
think Libertarians are people who in
general are in favor of individuals
controlling their own lives having their
property respected and so forth they can
believe that for any of a variety of
different reasons you could imagine and
I'm sure there exists Christians who
would say look if God wanted us to be
forced to be virtuous he would have done
it he gave us free will therefore you
should allow each person as I put it a
very long time ago to go to hell in his
own fashion you could have a utilitarian
who said You maximize utility by having
a society in which there's very little
government and so forth and so on and
you can have various other people so it
seems to me that what makes somebody's
libertarian is not the basis of his
arguments it's he reaches a certain
pattern of conclusions and as I say it's
not a bright line people will disagree
over some conclusion some people will
say well the best we can get is a 95
percent free Society because anything
more than that would collapse you're
still a Libertarian maybe a little less
every libertarian than somebody who
thinks you can get a hundred percent so
I guess that would be my my answer to
your question uh we don't have any more
time for question and answer
fortunately you can actually find these
men walking around so please save your
questions and grab them and ask them uh
as they walk around uh we do have time
though for the conclusions and for your
final vote so hold off on your vote not
yet but uh we will have the five-minute
summary by David Friedman
yeah I wanted first to say that there is
at least one thing that Jean and I sorry
there is at least one thing that Gene
and I clearly agree on and that is that
pork fest is better than Freedom Fest
[Applause]
but I don't think anybody here yet has
tried to sell me shares in a gold mine
and I can't remember any dogs or small
children at Freedom Fest
uh but that's that's a digression uh
I want to go back to the point that I
made briefly in answering a question
which is that the underlying
consequentialist argument is not there
is nothing a government could
conceivably do that would be good
because there are things governments
could conceivably do that would be good
it is that we have no way of setting up
institutions in which the good things
governments do will have a larger effect
than the bad things governments do and
as I say public Choice Theory it seems
to me is really the basis for those for
those arguments so let me take for a
moment the argument about tariffs
I don't know if it occurred to Russ
Roberts but we have a legal system in
which the government does impose tariffs
and nonetheless the bad consequences he
describes occur so what he requires is
not merely a legal system which the
government implies tariffs but in which
it always imposes the right tariffs and
in fact as you may know the old argument
for tariffs not the one he's making was
the infant industry argument the
argument was that a you could get an
industry started because of various
reasons that couldn't start itself in
the market and once it was there you
could drop the tariffs and have a
prosperous thing and that's not
logically not impossible economically
though it requires some additional
assumptions but if you actually think
about the politics of it infant infants
no Industries don't have any votes who
has votes senile Industries Industries
which are declining and need the
protection of the government I don't
have the time I could go into the
economics of that there are actually
reasons why the benefit to a declining
industry of having a tariff relative to
the costs to people is larger
similarly it is logically possible that
climate change is a terrible problem
which will kill all of us
but if you actually follow the argument
as I've been doing for a long time you
will discover that there is very little
evidence for that belief indeed the
serious people like the ipcc don't make
the catastrophic claims if you actually
look at their numbers they are talking
about making the world a little bit
poorer because we don't control climate
change uh
William nordhaus who got a Nobel Prize
for his work on that estimates that the
effect of climate change uh by the end
of the century will be to make World GNP
a few percent lower
uh nonetheless there are all sorts of of
politically profitable things you can do
with the claim that climate change is a
catastrophe and they do them uh
so in fact I mentioned before the case
of uh of the biofuels program which was
justified for that reason Gore himself
has conceded that part of the reason he
pushed it was he was running for
president and Iowa has early primaries
uh
so the basic argument here it seems to
me is that the institutions of
government will predictably not with
certainty but predictably have net bad
effects and you therefore don't want to
have government have powers even though
there are powers under some
circumstances have good effects so to
repeat my basic argument which is pretty
simple uh it has two parts the first is
that the claim that you should never
initiate coercion has implications
nobody believes in gene clearly doesn't
believe in them
he wants to modify that by saying well
yes you actually are allowed to initiate
coercion but then you have to pay
whatever damages the Court's uh impose
uh well if I run the courts that could
result in lots of coercion in my favor
uh I don't think there is a a good
mechanism uh for for doing that uh
and the second half of the argument is
that libertarianism is not only better
than Socialism or modern liberalism it's
a lot better
and that consequently uh you don't have
to persuade people that it is really
important that billionaires have
billions of dollars all you have to do
is to point out that they already think
it's important that poor there be fewer
poor people and they'd be better off and
that's the result you get with a less
Affair Society not the result you get
with a welfare state thank you
[Applause]
and the summary for the negative Gene
Epson
please be prepared to vote
well well I guess I guess the the
closest David and I had to do with to
what maybe you regard as a semantic
issue has to do with his idea about uh
committing a crime if I commit a crime
it's not a crime that's the way I would
put it I still committed a crime if if I
grabbed the flagpole on the way down to
save my own life I still committed a
crime if I steal the equipment uh in
order to save the world I still
committed a crime so I don't see now
those examples are rather far-fetched we
could we could make the argument that
maybe you know bad cases don't make good
law or whatever but I would only submit
to you that uh that those are simply
crimes potentially committed in
extenuating potentially whether
circumstances extenuating or not and all
for example it applies to cases in which
you caused some somebody's death but was
it intentional was it a completely
avoidable accident all of those
decisions have to be made the death was
caused it's an actionable claim it is a
crime and so I I guess you have to think
is David right to say well if I
committed the crime and I'm I and say
yes I would commit the crime that makes
it not a crime no it's a crime crime in
extenuating circumstances so that's why
I would say again the zero aggression
principle and the invasion of property
rights is indeed absolute but but again
as a practical matter for example when
uh when David tried just a moment ago to
address Russ Roberts problem and David
started to say plausibly well but Russ
the the tariffs that are imposed aren't
the right tasks all the rest of it I
still don't understand why David
wouldn't also say to Russ that don't you
understand as well that you're
penalizing everybody's right including
people of limited means their right to
buy what they want to buy why don't you
just try to appeal to them start a
website try to start a buy American
website
to try to appeal to them about the idea
to Target your problem with respect to
these particular communities that that's
all done
voluntarily you're violating people's
freedom please recognize that that's why
our default position is against you so
again David now we're trying to argue
something else all of it useful I
suppose but again why does David want to
do without the crucial role of the zero
aggression principle beyond that I guess
oh climate change once again all of all
that David said was right about climate
change although ironically if you're
actually read up on to the extent in
which we even know that carbon dioxide
is causing warming if you read Stephen
coonan who is a physicist who appointed
by Obama who wrote a book called
unsettled the truth of the matter is we
don't even know to what extent a carbon
dioxide is causing the warming versus
other Natural Factors especially since
the warming Trend was was very fast from
1910 to 1940 before carbon dioxide even
played a role so even it's all a mess
but aside from that can't we try to say
and every once in a while as in the case
of the vaccines I said to somebody well
you're forcing people to take a chemical
yes I know that you're supposedly saving
many more lives but just recognize
that's the one in fact we know
say to the war markers you plan to kill
more innocent people in order to achieve
some goal that's again the zero
aggression principle it keeps coming up
and so my plea to David is harness your
brilliant ability to make
consequentialist arguments harness it
and ground it in the zero aggression
principle every once in a while we might
convince a few people as indeed I can
say personally some people are convinced
of it of course there really are a lot
of people who have a tendency to believe
in Freedom even when they call
themselves progressives thanks
[Applause]
so it's time for you now to vote and on
the line is the famous Tootsie Roll
and a welcome to the free state from
these people living in the authoritarian
49. second place will only be a welcome
to the loser uh to the free state what's
in that Tootsie Roll
so please go to Soho vote.com and
register your vote
so the results from you people
uh the proposition the right way to
persuade people of libertarianism is by
showing them that they're that the
outcomes are superior by their standards
without any resort to the flawed
non-aggression principle
so starting out with yes that this
proposition is right uh we started with
28 percent
and we moved up to 36 percent
you're supposed to go
[Music]
for the negative we started with 32
percent but we moved up to 48 percent
[Applause]
so the winner of the Tootsie Roll is
Gene Epstein
[Applause]
second hand